iad aux dispositions de seconde sur
chrome experiments je sais que tout mon
respect si vous avez manqué il est de
retour aujourd'hui et sur chrome
experiments est un site web qui regroupe
des sites web innovant et qui sont donc
des sites web du futur voilà on a une
ligne à 1199 site web répertoriés dont
certains que l'ajustement bien commencé
avec rom music club c'est parti qu'est
ce que c'est que ce bordel tu as le
futur c'est beau non franchement fric
aux attentes ont battu assez génial bon
c'est quoi ce retour dans une heure
quand j'aurai fini tu joues avec ce
[ __ ] de sites et on passe à la suite
par d'enrichissement faites y compris
celle là tu payes d'autant fait par
exemple playes une grosse merde
bon voila si vous voulez jouer avec de
la musique pendant des années et finir
au chômage elle sur son site infinite
city alors ça à ces genres de ville en
finir leur vie dans une ville a fini ça
maintenant et comme ce possible les
nomme c'est exceptionnel ce qui se passe
le futur et la mecque pour de vrai c'est
quand même dingue c'est un site web
mexes pas logiciel un bon c'est chiant
voxel poids celle ci c'est que ça on va
jouer qu'un cube c'est ça va faire quoi
que ce cube on peut le bouger on peut le
modifier ses looks pas surfaite ça c'est
tu peux tu aurais jamais pu faire sur un
site loi de l'armance et des logiciels
de modélisation tu fais ça tu feras
modéliser un [ __ ] cube sur un site web
c'est incroyable médusé salaires beaux
mecs
or c'est beau jeu peut l'influencer dans
je peux changer l'angle de vue avec la
petite musique des abysses
wahou c'est beau ça sinon à les suivre
pour le futur il est cool mais il est
tranquille tranquille
ok je sais que ça c'est génial ça plaît
tu peux bouger les guerres du mal
et du coup tu peux envoyer le d'accord
petit paumé de l'amour regardez comme je
vous sers pour mes abonnés d'amour 50%
vie de l'amour comme ça vous faites sur
ces c'est bon ou c'est glauque one
million star online star registre
project attaque on part là dessus pour
de vrais battants abuser olala le site
du futur mais qui regroupe toutes les
étoiles
ouah mec c'est la galaxie on est tout
petit et la boillat le soleil génial où
tu peux créer une étoile est comme ça il
sera visible à temps malgré une étoile à
temps et bondit sur sa d'accord a
tellement des toiles dans le ciel je
peux payer 33 dollars pour donner un nom
à une étoile de ton choix d'un mets
salés business miles a pu vous arrêter
quoi domino non mais attends mais je
crois qu'on a trouvé le sait que si on
peut dire ce que je pense c'est stupide
orgasmique de tous les temps oh vous
avez joué vous aussi ceja puisque tu as
côté mystique mais sans le côté août et
une bonne grosse merde comme ça il n'y
était domino comme un bon puceau match
élèves est accro à la fin à la spirale
infernale
j'adore construit ça c'est chinois donc
c'est compliqué c'est sûr sont ils sont
trop dessus de nous regarder quelle est
cette mass mech
c'est cool mais vraiment effrayant c'est
hyper stressant arrêter ça m'a souri
tranquille ok nex lightsaber escape
psychose des lieux comment ces
rendez-vous surnom sur votre téléphone
ok bon tube sabre laser vous devez
d'abord calibré votre téléphone vous
êtes prêts à démarrer votre évasion à
temps mais ça va marcher ou pas oh mon
dieu oh mon dieu ça commence au bâton
mais ça va plus ça mais je pensais pas
du tout ça possible mais mec c'est quoi
cette google qu'elle est sauf
et ça marche puisque l'espace
la super bien ouais ouais super je me
suis enflammé mon skill djédjé mady
lancé le sabre j'avais oublié que
j'étais juste un puceau avec un
téléphone à la main bon dès qu'on a été
capturé à google envoie un message bravo
tu as été une énorme merde sur notre jeu
et ben mec ça c'était pas site web du
futur os machine mais yassine c'est quoi
ça d'accord on tue un truc de sable
maintenant c'est fantastique
mais non mais si mais si c'est ce qui se
passe regardez là c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal du tout ça me plaît beaucoup
sinon tu vas à la plage et en plus du
bronze mais en vrai on s'en rend pas
compte mais je pense que chaque site sur
lequel on va c'est une [ __ ] de
prouesses techniques vue connais un peu
des merdes
on se rend pas trop compte c'est quoi ça
déjà vu ces photos are you ready to play
with the ice hockey
ce qui sera fait mon visage mais
ouh là où c'est quoi
what the fuck arrêté de danser on veut
pas on en fait pas mal découpé mon
visage et du cou ça fait le truc avec
mon deuil
ce qui rend le truc hyper drôle c'est
cool c'est vraiment génial mais pas avec
mon deuil d'un génial meilleure
expérience du monde firestarter ça
m'intéresse à il ya un feu ok changer
les paramètres du feu qui finalement
ressemble plus à un amas de losanges car
bref voilà on a fait du feu et on est
toujours plus voici la adventures
machine de matteo un artiste français
extrêmement doué ceci est génial c'est
quand on va fêter leur la musique mais
en mieux que choisit un beat dans les
carrés rouges par exemple ça ok on se
sort didier ou pas alors de l'arrière
fait voix juste une caméra pour david
guetta ok elle est prêt on ajoute un
bleu d'alou leurs proies digéré la
tension on rajoute à jean-paul
et roy je t'attends vol
erwan tasse en pole et voilages et
envoie du rêve
j'aimerais du rêve alors j'ai fait cinq
clics merci à des who et lucide de
l'année parce que c'est un type 2 mais
amadeo mais c'est toujours ça space lem
qu'elle faisait que cette chose permet
mais vous rendez compte que maintenant
on peut jouer à ça sur un [ __ ] de
navigateurs il faut qu'on chope des
medikits et les pop corn et on veut
atteindre la terre c'est génial on a
deux trips under the moonlight mais non
mais non mais attends je peux avancer
mais oui mais oui regardez le futur il
est pas beau mais franchement avoir sa
cendrillon je me répète mais c'est vrai
c'est fantastique le précurseur à la
gandhi chic sur 1m le ca multiples mon
curseur et lequel est le bon du coup on
sait pas howe
c'est génial ça sert à 10 tort et c'est
que ça au fait à quoi faut il faut dit
il faut tordre la masse saoud oui c'est
une boule antistress virtuel du coup ça
déstresse pas du tout voilà qui demande
c'est quoi ce truc encore de lsd la has
et comme le triste invention qui cette
fois on va contrôler son coeur qu'elle
reste en vie à temps j'adore j'adore sur
des jeux visent à vue on dirait que je
like des photos instagram n'est pas du
tout et je la maintiens envie tu fais
rien baa
elle est en train de mourir ok ça va pas
c'est quoi ce qui est bizarre avec ce
côté du scotch et un déménagement sur le
visage j'arrête je sorte d'histoire vers
l'aide spyder wade a fuck ouah ah mais
c'est horrible qu'ils sont fin prêtes à
sanaa
j'aime pas du tout en fait le but c'est
la personne qui est à toi mon gars c'est
du cash contre une araignée j'attendais
tellement mauvais que même une araignée
nous met mal quoi ah mais tu peux pas la
dégager mecs et techniquement c'est
impossible à temps valve a dégagé comme
ça on voit la dga elle n'arrive plus à
suivre
oh oui je les oui maintenant tu n'auras
gauche sa toilette arrête tout accroché
aux as après plus jamais je n'y a pas de
cette vidéo sur tous ses sites web du
futur
et croyez moi le futur ça va déchirer
voilà ma conclusion est belle mais ça
vous a plu pour se tourner très vite
dans une prochaine souligne deuxième
vidéo sur les sites web futur ce qui le
restera encore au moins 95 ap ap
n'hésitez pas à me le dire je vous dis à
très une prochaine vidéo portez vous
bien car tout le monde pitt et moi je
retourne sur la avait durant machina